[Music] [
Music]
This is a failed policy, because this policy of detention
revolts the families more. It revolts the youth more and they are born.
The pressure is greater on the families. It is a
failed process. I can tell you about it. It is a
failed policy in the truest sense of the word,
because when my son is detained, I want to keep
demanding. I want to keep creating confusion in the matter.  I don't
want to sit and be silent and hide until they give me a body.
[Music]
I don't have proof that Fadi is alive. I don't
have a death certificate, nor do I
have a health document. He's wounded. He's a prisoner. He needs a document. I want a
document because he's a martyr.
[Music]
I hope to God that I can bury my son.  He does not stay
in the refrigerator because I want to honor him. Our Lord, honor him with
martyrdom. We have a duty to honor him with burial. Our Lord honored him with
martyrdom. And I have to bury him. To honor him, we will go to God, but the refrigerator. [Music] [Applause] [Music] I want to carry his coffin. I want to carry his coffin and take it and bury it. And I am left walking
at the funeral
and resting.  I am not the one who will rest my son Fadi, who
will rest at that time. All the mothers of the martyrs have the same
dream
[music]